hey ellie what's up my main question for
you today is
my my husband and i are not seeing eye
to eye on
um on a specific issue and i am of two
minds as to whether i need to dig my
heels in
and really try to drive my point home or
if i just need to kind of throw up my
hands and say all right well this is
part of your grieving process so i'm
just going to be here while you work it
out
okay go for it so
back in november my husband lost his
brother
in a uh in a car accident and it was
sudden and nobody saw it come in and it
hit him really really hard
i'm so sorry yeah thank you um
so so with that um
as as my brother-in-law's um estate is
finally starting to come into line and
we're starting to figure out how it's
going to be
you know taken care of essentially
there's this one item
uh it's this race car is what it is
race cars yeah my my brother-in-law
like he he was like a minor celebrity in
our community and like one of his things
was he would take the car down to the
track and
win these races and things and cool
so yeah i mean it's not i'm a huge
fan i'm a huge fan of both minor
like minor celebrities in towns i love
that that makes me so happy
and i love ricky bobby and so you have
just met my heart on two different
fronts and so
i am so grateful that you called today
okay so
your brother-in-law was a minor celeb
which i love love small town minor celeb
race car driver and he passed away
suddenly in a car wreck unrelated
and then you and your husband are having
a disagreement
yes because my husband wants to buy out
his the rest of his siblings for this
car and i just feel like it's a bad idea
why does he want to buy the race car uh
well when i
uh of the previous times that we've
talked about it he's he tells me that
you know he really wants to
get the car and do further modifications
to it that he knew that his brother
wanted them but didn't get a chance to
and he wants to take it down and do the
racing and that kind of thing
is he a car guy is he a car racer guy
well ish and that's that's part of why i
have my reservations because if he were
even like a casual racer i probably
wouldn't even raise my eyebrows
but the last time he took one of his own
cars
to the racetrack was like 2018. okay
and so why why does are his brother and
sisters
like why don't they just give him the
car if it means a lot to him why don't
they just give it to him
uh it's just a question of well because
my brother-in-law passed away he didn't
have a will so
it's just a question of like who all
that legal stuff is what they're waiting
on
okay does he have a family too that's
that's parsing through everything
uh no he he died single okay all right
so is it is the question about the money
is it about
his safety what is your concern here
it's it's partially money and it's also
partially just like i'm not really
understanding why he's so
hung up about the car because like i
said he's not even a casual
racer um oh the car has nothing to do
with racing
oh i i figured that much but it's just i
don't know i feel like sometimes he kind
of
throughout this whole process he's
latched on to some odd
in my opinion odd mementos of his
brother like
you know his brother had asthma do we
want to keep his medical equipment and
i'm looking at my husband like why would
we want to keep his medical equipment
when either one of us has asthma
yeah so did he love his brother
very much they were they were very close
they're pretty close how old
how far apart were they in age uh five
years but
like they were like my my husband's the
the second youngest and the brother that
passed away was the baby of the family
uh okay so they had to they had to grind
it out together down there at the bottom
right
yeah how how old is your husband
he is uh turning 39. okay
so every single thing that he gives away
that y'all get rid of is
a little is one more piece of your of
your brother-in-law that's turning into
a vapor
every little piece and so you can look
at that at that
um asthma equipment and go
why would we need a nebulizer
and your husband doesn't hear that at
all
that represents a little piece of his
brother and we sell the nebulizer we
give that nebulizer away
and then there goes another little piece
and then another little piece
and the thing about race cars the thing
about
modific modifying the thing about racing
is now you've got a project you've got a
spirit that we're going to keep alive
not in things but you can never fill
that thing right it's about making
meaning
finding meaning on the back end of this
deal and it's going to be we're going to
keep going
right we're going to keep going we're
going to keep going i'm going to do
these things
and man a few months out people can
spend a lot of money
you hear about people burning through
their inheritances that way they go do
some daredevil things
i've heard of veterans who will go try
to relive something
to honor a lost fellow soldier so man
people can
really go to some great links to try to
make meaning try to find meaning but
really what they're trying to do is is
they're trying to say i don't want to
say goodbye
and the longer i can keep this alive the
longer there's there's
the person i love than i lost to stand
with me
have you how has your husband grieved
this loss
uh we well we we've run like the full
gamut of grieving in our household we've
you know done the crying and the
screaming and the irritability and
for for most of it i've kind of just
kind of sat back and just
let him work through what he's working
through
um but it's just with this car like you
know we
we have a one car garage and no driveway
so like where are you even going to work
on it you know that sort of thing
and so what i want you to do is not try
to have
no that's not fair it's going to say
don't try to have rational conversations
because this is an irrational project
does that make sense no i i picked up on
that and that's part of my frustration
because i don't know how to
because out of the two of us i'm much
more the more practical one so i don't
really know how to
right so handle all this stuff
so let's see what numbers are getting
thrown around
like a purchase price well the
the purchase price so much isn't the
issue it's only about like three to four
thousand dollars i think
okay um my concern with the price is
mostly
you know the cost of the modifications
that he wants to do and then we're
looking at upping
our um car insurance because we already
have three vehicles now we're adding a
fourth
um okay and then like i said just just
the storage issue because we have
you know most most of our cars are you
know parked down on the street right now
because of
you know the town we live in yeah so
it's not like you know it's not like
we have a nice big suburban house with
multi-car garages and driveways you can
do whatever you wanted
so one thing that takes down couples
that most people never fully grasp until
it happens to them
is what i would call competitive
grieving
meaning for some people somebody passes
away suddenly in november
it is a hard hard thanksgiving christmas
season
really hard and then january is a little
bit lighter
february is the gray months but we're
starting to make peace with what
happened here we're starting to pick up
the pieces
and then all of a sudden someone's
walking alongside us and they just fall
off
right and suddenly it's like dude will
you just
like we know this is a big deal but we
all got to get up tomorrow and they
don't seem like they can get up
right and so one thing i always want
couples to
be graceful with one another is that
balance between you got to get up and go
to work you got gotta get up and do
these things and
man and
everybody grieves differently if it's
three thousand bucks
and he can come up with a storage plan
that's one that
here's the thing he's not gonna work on
it you know that i know that
he may race it once in some big ceremony
maybe
maybe right i think after like the one
year anniversary or something yeah it'll
be a thing right
and so for three thousand dollars you
could
that's that's money right but the the
reality is
once this estate gets settled your
brothers and his brothers and sisters
aren't gonna charge them three thousand
bucks you're gonna give them the car
and if they do charge them three
thousand bucks come on guys let them
have the car for crying out loud you
aren't gonna do anything with it
and if he can come up with a storage
plan
that's not gonna break the bank that's
that's gonna be well thought out so
that's where you can put some of this on
him because some of this
is a fantasy it's a myth it's a way
to keep a ghost at the table
and every time you say okay make me a
plan for what this will actually look
like
how are we gonna afford this here's our
budget here's the reality of the money
we have here's what the
track cost here's what running the cars
at the track scouts and those are
expensive right the tires and all
stuff's really expensive
make me a plan for how we're gonna do
this
and then some of that may just fall away
right and that may be a heartbreaking
reality moment for him where he realizes
we can't afford to do this
or he may circle back and say hey billy
bob down the street's gonna let us store
the car there it's three thousand bucks
i can pay for it
um we can pay for this can i just do
this and for 300 bucks sure high five
way to go
and then we're going to budget every
month and we're going to not just go buy
bumpers and new i don't i'm going to
start talking carburetors i'm trying to
suck a car guy which i'm
super not um we can't get out of control
because we're going to have this
constrained budget here
or you can
ask him to come up with a broader plan
for everything all at once and then you
can say
are you scared to let your brother go
because he loved you and i want us to
work towards letting him go
be in peace right and that may still
mean you end up with a race car in your
driveway for a season so be it
um but it also may mean that he's gonna
do the hard work of grieving so here's
one thing i do want you all to do
together
i want you to get david kessler's book
finding meaning it's the best book on
grief i've ever read and i want you all
to read it together
james will put it in the show notes here
it's by david kessler it's called
finding meaning
it's a masterpiece but it's something
you all can read together and it will
give you
the opportunity to ask him some hard
questions that are going to come from
the book not from him
and it's a really clean easy read
and it's not anything complicated or
hard but it's going to let him express
some of his thoughts and some of his
feelings
and if making meaning is hey once a year
i
pull this thing out of the drive when
it's three thousand bucks man i don't
care about that
you know what you don't have a space in
your garage right so that is a thing
right
but if it comes down to i don't care
about three thousand bucks four thousand
dollars for
to hang on to something for my brother
that's not a big deal in in the grand
scheme of things
if it is i'm gonna go mortgage the house
and do these things that's when you as
his partner in life
as somebody who mutually helps hold him
accountable or he holds you accountable
we can't afford to do this we're not
going to go bankrupt in the memory of
your brother
that's not going to be a good
stewardship of his memory that's going
to drive us underwater
and that's not a good way to remember
your brother
but this book is going to give you all a
step-by-step process to walk through
that so
i know that's so messy everybody out
there this has been hard with covet too
right this has been really hard with
kovit this idea of
grieving together my wife and i grieve
differently at different paces at
different speeds and different ways
i mean that's hard we've been together a
long time
a way to cut through that is to say hey
is this about this car is this about
your brother are you really sad
that your brother's not with us anymore
are you really sad that you had this
business that just went away
are you really sad that somebody
betrayed you because
man then all of a sudden getting angry
doesn't make a lot of sense
just sitting here in the suck of it for
a while does
and then i'm gonna walk with you
tomorrow cause we gotta get up we gotta
shower we gotta go to work
right but it's about just
grieving and we all do it and it sucks
and it's a part of life which is why we
need each other right so i need zach and
james and kelly all of our friends
my wife so we need each other because
hard things happen